France en terre alibadou Marion lourd le
69 le grand entretien de la matinale
avec Marion lourd notre invité
aujourd'hui est le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de
l'Assemblée nationale député MoDem vos
questions vos réactions chers auditeurs
au 01 45 24 7000 ou sur l'application
FRANCE INTER bonjour Jean-Louis
bourlange bonjour et bienvenue le 24
octobre vous prononciez un discours sur
le conflit au proch
discours très applaudi dans un hémicycle
profondément divisé il y a 2 jours à
peine ambiance houleuse en commission
sous votre présidence au cours de
l'audition de l'ancienne ambassadeur de
France en Israël Gérard Haro on parle
souvent de l'importation du conflit en
France est-ce que vous diriez que le
conflit a été importé jusqu'à
l'assemblée nationale qu'il divise
aujourd'hui profondément politiquement
non je crois pas que l'ambiance est été
houleuse autour de gerérard Aro ça a été
Gérard a fait une intervention
extrêmement intéressante complexe
d'ailleurs complexe avec des on voyait
bien sa propre incertitude son propre
désarroi mais il avait eu des des
échanges assez durs avec l'un des
parlementaires monsieur Meyer Habib mais
là là il est venu ça c'est ça s'est
passé de façon très satisfaisante mais
ça n'empêche pas que il y a une très
très grande perplexité sur ce qu'il faut
faire au Moyen-Orient dans ma commission
et alors sur l'importation du du conflit
je crois que c'est c'est c'est c'est
évident nous sommes nous sommes dans une
situation où nous avons une communauté
une communauté arabomusulmane qui est
très très sensible aux violences que que
que l'État d'Israël fait subir aux
populations palestiniennne et nous avons
des centaines de milliers de Juifs
400000 ou 500000 juifs qui très
logiquement sont confrontés même si on
queles que soi les responsabilités qu'on
puisse attribuer à l'État hébreu sont
très très
légitimement dans une situation
d'extrême angoisse moi je je vois j'ai
beaucoup d'amis juifs qui disent on a
été seul entre 40 et 45 nous sommes
maintenant nous avons peur nous avons
peur d'aller à la synagogue nous avons
peur d'aller dans les restaurants nous
avons peur pour nos enfant à l'école et
nous avons le sentiment que une fois de
plus on on va être seul et ça c'est
c'est quelque chose de terriblement
angoissant et c'est pourquoi
personnellement j'étais très favorable à
à la à la manifestation quel que soit
les critiques assez fortes que je fais à
l'égard du gouvernement néaniaahou la
manifestation contre l'antisémitisme
cétait absolument nécessaire que les
Français se mobilisent j'aurais même
aimé qu'ils le fassent encore un peu
plus h c'est aujourd'hui il y a demain
il y a un appel à manifester de du musée
d'arrêt d'histoire du Judaïsme jusque
jusque au à l'Institut du monde arabe
est-ce que cette manifestation aussi
vous semble bienvenue elle se veut
absolument à partisane elle appelle à la
paix oui la la je je crois que
euh la la la paix il y a on manifeste
contre l'antisémitisme on manifeste
contre le racisme on manifeste pour la
paix je crois que il faut se centrer sur
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est
aujourd'hui hein le le racisme c'est
évidemment un poison absolu mais
aujourd'hui c'est l'antisémitisme et
c'est la guerre les les deux les deux
poisons contre lesquels il faut il faut
manifester je crois que c'est c'est ça
alors donc elle est bienvenue cette
manifestation moi je oui je je n'en sais
enfin c'est pas la peine non plus de
multiplier les manifestations je crois
que ce qui était très bien dans la dans
la démarche de de de dimanche dernier ça
a été qu'elle a été appelée par les deux
représentants des assemblées élus au
suffrage universel direct ou indirect
madame Bron pivé et Monsieur et Monsieur
Larcher que elle était donc profondément
transpartisane et et qu'elle et qu'elle
se centrait sur l'antisémitisme et que
c'était donc une valeur de d'unification
d'union nationale le la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme enfin on a quand même on
a quand même une responsabilité
historique les les les Français à cause
de Pétin à cause de Vichi mais c'était
l'État français hein on a on a laissé
tomber et on a même accompagné la
déportation des Juifs on a cette immense
tâche dans notre histoire et je
comprends qu'on on doiv à tout moment se
mobiliser pour y répondre mais il
nempêche il nempêche que je pense qu'on
va en parler que je suis absolument
terrifié par la façon dont se déroule le
conflit au Moyen-Orient on va y venir
justement quand on parlait de cette
audition de l'ancienne ambassadeur de
France en Israël et aux États-Unis
Gérard Haro il disait qu'Israël se
livrait je le cite à un nettoyage
ethnique au détail en 6 Jordanie avec
des colons qui s'emparaient de terres
qui ne leur appartiennent pas avec le
soutien de l'armée est-ce que vous
reprendrz ces mots puisque la bataille
elle se joue aussi ça peut paraître
dérisoire mais tout est symb dans cette
histoire elle se joue aussi sur le plan
sémantique elle se joue oui enfin sur le
nettoyage ethnique ça me paraît assez
juste à vrai dire et je je je suis de
ceux qui dès le discours auquel vous
avez fait allusion j'ai toujours mis
l'accent sur l'importance du dossier 6
jordanien il y a Gaza mais il y a aussi
la sisjordanie et ce que mène et c'est
une politique que nous combattons nous
français chez Monsieur netanahou depuis
de longues années c'est une politique
qui effectivement vise à chasser euh les
les les les agriculteurs les paysans
Palestiniens de leur terre avec une
complicité d'ailleurs souvent très mal
ressentie par les soldats de tsal mais
une complicité et une espèce de
d'organisation semi-publique des colons
qui est quelque chose de très très
malsin et moi je je crois que le le le
drame c'est le drame de tout ce qui se
fait actuellement en Israël c'est que si
on essaie de comprendre ce qui soutend
politiquement la démarche ça cons
consiste pour Gaza à dire que les
Gazaouis disparaissent vers l'Égypte et
pour la sisjordanie que les
sisjordaniens disparaissent chez le roi
Abdallah en Jordanie or ça le règlement
de la question palestinienne par le vide
c'est absolument d'abord c'est IR
réaliste et c'est moralement
inacceptable le député les républicains
de la 8e circonscription des Français de
l'étranger meilleur Habib cette
circonscription qui comprend notamment
Israël mais pas seulement meilleur Habib
a eu ces mots dans votre commission
cette guerre est une guerre de
civilisation un juif ne sera jamais un
colon en Judée vous n'avez pas réagi
mais qu'avez-vous pensé en l'écoutant je
sais pas je suis je connais bien
monsieur meerabib qui est un député
chaleureux sympathique et cetera mais je
suis en désaccord avec lui sur la
question israélienne depuis le début
c'est un ami personnel de Monsieur
netaniaahou c'est ce qui est son droit
il s'est identifié totalement à au au
revirement d'Israël qui a quand même
profondément changé politique au cours
des 20 dernières années moi j'appelle un
chat un chat et ce qui se fait en
sjordanie une colonisation mais donc ce
n'est pas une guerre de civilisation à
vos yeux qui est en train de joueriv une
guerre de civilisation ça qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire si si on me dit que le
Hamas représente le contraire même de
toutes les valeurs de civilisation qui
sont les nôtres c'est évident je l'ai
dit d'ailleurs dans ce discours auquel
vous faites allusion j'ai dit que le
Hamas était se livrit à des était un
mouvement terroriste euh qu'il était un
mouvement qui pratiquait des crimes de
guerre et qu'il il allait même jusqu'à
des crimes contre l'humanité puisque
derrière la mise en cause d'Israël il y
avait la mise en cause des Juifs en tant
que Juifs donc je crois effectivement
que là c'est c'est un peu un lieu commun
de dire que nous avons une opposition
civilisationnelle avec nos valeurs
républicaines démocratiques le respect
du droit l'égalité le le le respect des
personnes humaines que nous avons une
opposition totale au au au valeur de
Hamas mais je je rappelle que le
mouvement palestinien dans son origine
qui a toujours été complexe
maladroit violent et cetera avait aussi
des racines qui étaient des racines
humanistes il y avait beaucoup de
chrétiens d'abord même même d'ailleurs à
l'extrême gauche du mouvement
palestinien rappelez-vous George abach
ou des gens comme ça il y avait des
chrétiens il y avait des laïques il y
avait des musulmans ce qui est terrible
aussi ça c'est dans ce qui se passe
actuellement c'est une double capture
par le fanatisme religieux de part et
d'autre les religieux n'avaient jamais
été au pouvoir en Israël avant netanahou
ils sont au pouvoir et ils font des
dégâts ils font des dégâts en S Jordanie
ils font des dégâts sur l'explanade des
mosquées ce sont vraiment des des des
gens qui qui sont des des bouts de feu
et puis de l'autre côté le Hamas c'est
une régression absolument fondamentale
desun d'un droit d'un peuple peuple
palestinien à être souverain et libre et
parlons de la guerre telle qu'elle se
déroule au Proche Orient et la question
des otages il y a des dizaines de
familles qui vont cet après-midi
demander au Premier ministre israélien
la libération de leurs proches détenus
justement par le Hamas on apprend c'est
une information France Inter que le
ministre des armées est au Qatar pays
réputé médiateur dans la région il a
raison Sébastien lecnu de faire du Qatar
l'interlocuteur sur les h moi je je
crois que Sébastien le Cornu est un
c'est un émissaire très bien choisi par
le Président de la République c'est un
homme très habile qui est très très très
conscient très réaliste et extrêmement
euh pont à la manœuvre quelqu'un qui
travaille qui s'y colle si vous voulez
maintenant sur la question des otages je
crois qu'on peut rien dire on peut on
peut rien dire sinon qu'il faut les
libérer mais le la la les manœuvres par
lesquelles on arrivera à libérer des
otages ne peuvent pas être être connus
et commentés sans sans faire peser sur
tout ça sur tout le processus des rich
je ne sais pas du tout les cartes que
nous avons en main dans cette
négociation ce que je constate
simplement c'est que c'est nouveau qui
Israël attache peu d'importance réelle
je ne dis pas d'importance médiatique
mais d'importance réelle à la question
des otages ça a toujours été une
question absolument centrale à tel point
qu'ils ont contre un Israélien ils
avaient libéré 1000 Palestiniens et et
là manifestement c'est une priorité qui
est passée au tout à fait au au second
au 3e au 4e plan de de la part de de
Monsieur netanahou et c'est quand même
tragique pour toutes ses familles vous
arrivez à définir aujourd'hui le but de
guerre d'Israël non je c'est la question
centrale je crois qu'au-delà de la
discussion les trêves le CESS et le feu
moi depuis le premier jour depuis le 8
enfin le 8 octobre quand on a commencé à
réfléchir je me dis je ne vois pas ce
que veut faire Israël la guerre ça n'est
pas la violence la guerre ça n'est pas
le la loi du talion la guerre ça n'est
pas la vengeance la guerre c'est
l'utilisation de la force et de la
violence pour atteindre des objectifs
politiques précis on a tous lu clus Vitz
la guerre c'est la la continuation de la
politique par d'utre moyen et je ne vois
pas dans la façon dont Israël conduit
cette guerre à quoi ça peut qu quelle
est la signification que ces opérations
peuvent avoir je crois pas détruire le
Hamas voilà ils l'ont dit c'est ça c'est
c'est une blague écoutez le Hamas
qu'est-ce que c'est quand on aura
détruit 1500 ou 2000 2000 militaires
détruit quelques dizaines de kilomètres
de de tunnel détruit des des caches
d'armes et si on ne prend pas en main si
Israël ne prend pas en main le d'une
manière ou d'une autre le destin de Gaza
dans 3 ans dans 4 ans ça ça sera ça aura
reparu c'est c'est pas un objectif le
seul objectif qui paraît compréhensible
c'est de rendre et ça c'est très grave
c'est de rendre le territoire de Gaza
inhabitable parce que l'idée
fondamentale c'est que les Gazaouis
doivent disparaître du territoire de
Gaza alors ça ça ça ne repose sur rien
puisque il y a aucune raison que le
maréchal siici le chef de l'État
égyptien accueille 2300000 personnes qui
en plus ne seraiit pas tout à fait de
ses amis politiquement parce que les
rapports entre les Frères musulmans et
et et et et l'Égypte sont pas sont pas
bons oui c'est moins qu'on puiss dire
ils sont interdit en Égypte oui
absolument mais de toute manière c'est
c'est ce ce n'est pas ce n'est pas une
option et ass sis Jordanie non plus les
l'évacuation des colons ce n'est pas une
option il faut absolument que Israël
retrouve c'est très très compliqué très
difficile et ce que montrait Gérard
rarot quand il est venu devant notre
commission c'est que c'est exactement le
contraire de l'état d'esprit d'Israël
aujourd'hui pour des raisons qu'on peut
comprendre il faut retrouver une
relation de coopération que que veut
mais néanahou nous dit je ne veux pas
occuper Gaza très bien seulement il a
des un statut juridique d'occupant de de
de de d'occupant qu'est-ce qu'il fait
moi je voudrais savoir non pas ce qu'il
veut pas faire mais savoir ce qu'il veut
faire et ça on ne le sait pas comme vous
comme vous avez comme vous l'avez dit à
l'instant on ne le sait pas pourquoi
est-ce que l'Europe ne dit rien
Jean-Louis bourlange ah l'Europe c'est
moi j'ai j'ai dit à plusieurs reprises
devant ma commission que j'étais un
Européen convaincu mais nétais pas un
Européen heureux je pessimiste je sais
pas je suis toujours pessimiste je vais
essayé de me libérer de cette défroque
mais je je pense qu'on a énormément de
difficultés à euh à assumer tout un
d'abord les Allemands que que je crois
pas qu'on soit dans une relation
d'hostilité aux Allemands du tout mais
je crois que les Allemands sont
profondément troublés par la remise en
Cuse de tous leurs fondamentaux et
qu'ils ont du mal à déterminer une
politique forte fondamentaux vis-à-vis
des Chinois des Russes des Américains de
l'écologie et cetera et et et nous euh
et et en plus on a énormément de
difficultés à passer d'une Europe qui a
été construite pour faire la paix pour
vivre la paix donc une Europe qui qui
volontiers un peu l'Europe des
bisounours euh à une Europe qui doit se
se positionner on a eu raison on a eu
raison sur le sur le Moyen-Orient on a
dit depuis toujours qu'il fallait
appliquer au Moyen-Orient la même
logique que l'Europe c'est-à-dire
reconnaître ceux d'en face pour assoir
sa propre sécurité mais quand on a dit
ça on a rien fait on manque de volonté
on manque d'unité et ça c'est une
question très importante j'espère que
les européennes vont être l'occasion
d'un sursaut les élections européennes
mais je n'en suis pas sûr on verra le 9
juin prochain puisque si on parle
d'Europe il y a la question de
l'élargissement est-ce est-ce que
l'Ukraine a vocation à rentrer dans
l'Union européenne à court terme à court
terme ça c'est c'est c'est c'est ça
serait très difficile je crois que le
que l'Union européenne doit s'élargir et
qu'elle doit s'élargir sur d'autres
bases que ce qu'on a fait jusqu'à
présent c'est-à-dire sur des bases
géopolitiques avant on voulez que les
gens soient d'accord sur le marché
intérieur et cetera et bon il faut
évidemment qu'il respecte la démocratie
maintenant ce sont les valeurs de
civilisation comme vous comme vous les
comme vous les qualifiez et ce sont les
valeurs géopolitique donc de ce point de
vuelà l'Ukraine est un leader bon
maintenant pour rentrer moi j'ai fait un
rapport
à que j'ai présenté à la Commission en
juillet dernier sur le processus
d'élargissement et j'estime qu'il faut
complètement revoir la méthode il faut
se mettre d'accord très rapidement sur
tous les principes et avoir une sorte de
d'adhésion de principe au départ ensuite
il faut avoir un cheminement politique
par politique parce que les pays je
pense au Balcans he pas seulement à
l'Ukraine pas laisser les Balcans dehors
alors que il faut faire ça et à la fin
il faut faire rentrer tout le monde dans
les institutions mais ça implique des
conversions énormes la lutte contre la
corruption en Ukraine c'est c'est les
écuries d'ogias de Hercule c'est un
travail énorme qu'il faut entreprendre
oui ah ben je sais pas Z un ski a quand
même quelques qualités c'est un hercul
un peu David en attendant en attendant
il est un peu l'impression d'être oublié
hein volodimir zelanski il déploore un
ralentissement des livraisons de
munitions notamment depuis et le le tout
façon il y a l'Arménie qui est oublié et
l'Arménie c'est pas fini hein quand on
voit la la les les virvoltes de Monsieur
Erdogan ce qui quand même directement
intéressé sur le dossier arménien
l'attitude extrêmement agressive des des
azerbaïdjanais qui ont même choisi le
conflit politique avec les États-Unis
c'est pas quant au quant à à à l'Ukraine
c'est vital c'est vital il faut Biden
fait ce qu'il peut mais la chambre des
représentant bloc l'affaire comment temp
oui est-ce que volodimir Zelenski doit
organiser des élections même en contexte
de guerre je crois je crois que c'est
leur infire mais je crois pas que ce
soit c'est pas leaire les Britanniques
l'avaient fait pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale elle était elle était finie
hein elle était finie sauf au Japon elle
était fini les élections ont eu lieu en
ont eu lieu en juillet vous savez ce qu'
avait dit Staline à Churchill quand il a
accueilli à podam Churchill a dit je
serit peut-être virer parce que Staline
lui a dit comment mais j'espère que vous
avez pris vos précautions Jean-Louis
bourlange une question institutionnelle
politique puisque le le président
espérait élargir le champ du référendum
au sujet de société comme par exemple
l'immigration finalement on l'a vu avec
la réunion à sintdenis cette nuit hier
soir ça ne sera ça ne sera pas le cas
est-ce que vous le regrettez non moi je
ne suis pas je ne suis pas un champion
du un fan du référendum je crois que le
référendum c'est une machine à
simplifier à opposer quand on est
philosophe on a lu Hegel on sait que
Hegel c'est la thèse l'antithèse et la
synthèse mais le référendum c'est Hegel
sans la synthèse gu sans la synthèse
donc la thèse l'antithèse donc ça ça ça
antagonise énormément ça ça ne marche
les référendum que quand tout le monde
est d'accord et ça permettait de
résoudre le problème de la loi
immigration par exemple qui va avoir mal
à trou ma le problème de la lo
immigration ce sont les travaux
pratiques c'est extrêmement difficile de
gérer de façon rigoureuse l'immigration
sans être extrêmement brutale c'est ça
le problème on voit si on est brutal
comme comme les Danois on fait quelque
chose de très rigoureux mais c'est un
peu assez inacceptable donc on on on on
on fasseille autour de tout ça c'est un
problème c'est vraiment un problème de
travaux pratiques immigration nous les
États européens ont énormément de mal à
contrôler effectivement les flus
migratoires et c'est et contrairement à
ce que dit le PAP c'est pas un signe
d'indifférence c'est un signe
d'impuissance peut-être collective he
pas l'impuissance simplement du
gouvernement français parce que ça fait
40 ans qu'on est comme ça le passionné
d'histoire que vous êtes ira-t-il voir
Napoléon de rid lesescott le film
événement la semaine prochaine qui débar
j'irais sans doute le voir mais ce que
j'en ai ce que j'en ai euh lu euh je
suis pas un admirateur fanatique enfin
je suis un grand admirateur de Napoléon
sur le plan personnel mais pas de son
entreprise politique extérieure mais là
je je crois que la la vision de que je
ce que j'ai vu dans les critiques me
paraît extrêmement caricatural bon ben
écoutez vous nous direz ce que vous en
avez pensé merci infiniment président
bourlange d'avoir été l'invité de France
Inter ce matin à suivre le carrefour